if there's anything positive that we can
say about Donald Trump's reign of terror
so far it's that the religious right
hasn't been as vocally and publicly
involved as they have been with some
other Republican administrations but we
might not be able to say that much
longer
lunatic Christian mega church pastor
Robert Jeffress is one of trumps
evangelical advisors and he has put out
a statement
brace yourselves get the kids out of the
room he has put out a statement saying
that Donald Trump has God's authority to
take out Kim jong-un the North Korean
leader he put out a statement just a
couple days ago where he said quote when
it comes to how we should deal with
evildoers the Bible in the book of
Romans is very clear God has endowed
rulers full power to use whatever means
necessary including war to stop evil in
the case of North Korea God has given
Trump authority to take out Kim jong-un
why do I feel like if the Donald Trump
Russia blackmail file P tapes exist
Robert Jeffress was the camera man in
the room this guy's a real piece of work
right truly bottom of the barrel and in
case you were wondering not only does
God approve of Trump taking out Kim
jong-un Voldemort and Gandalf have also
cleared Trump to go after him it's also
crazy to me to think about why these
people do this why these pastors make
these ridiculous claims because if they
turn out to be wrong does that mean that
God is fallible or that he's not
all-powerful or does it mean that their
credibility is just ruined these are
they don't have a direct connection to
him they're totally unfalsifiable
statements like how could it be wrong
that God has cleared Trump to go after
kim jeong-hoon
if Trump doesn't go after him then hey
God still cleared him he just ended up
not like it yeah these statements cannot
be proven wrong that's why they're so
ridiculous I guess it could just turn
out to be a bad idea which this
obviously would be on its face to begin
with Robert Jeffress has said in the
past that former President Barack Obama
paved the way for the Antichrist maybe
that's true if he meant Donald Trump but
I don't know who exactly he was thinking
of where do I agree with Robert Jeffress
he did call Mormonism a cult when Mitt
Romney was running in 2012 during the
Republican primary so I do agree with
Robert Jeffress at least about one thing
even if you consider geopolitics based
on religious texts valid I caution you
that a huge portion of evangelicals want
total Cataclysm and destruction because
they're waiting around for the rapture
or the apocalypse or whatever you call
it they believe that when it all gets
broken down they will end up in heaven
and all the sinners won't or whoever the
bad people are Jews well I don't even
know so violence and death isn't a
deterrent to them and that's why it's so
dangerous to pay attention to what these
sort of apocalyptic evangelical
Christians want especially when they
have a role in the White House now and
they talk about climate change what do
they even care if the rapture is going
to come in the next 20 years yeah it's
going to be great for them that it did
this is where they will live their life
out in eternity somewhere I don't even
really know by the way why is being an
evangelical pastor a credential to be
taken seriously on foreign policy
matters everyone should know you can
only take Southern Baptist Series right
on foreign policy that's the only group
when it comes to religious texts that I
that I listen to I am kidding about that
because I just no matter what I say you
could have picked Jews you could have
put by the big the athletes doesn't
matter than any group yeah it just seems
funnier to say Southern Baptists like a
really specific group of Christians
let's take a break people discussing
this with us on our reddit discussion
forum david pakman.com slash read it
back after this today's program
sponsored in part by tag adapt the
hosting specialists whether you need
dedicated server solutions virtual
private servers cloud server options
custom server solutions
colocation services whatever you need
for your business or project taga dab
and their expert hosting specialists and
support will set you up with what works
for your business or project and their
hosting services support a really wide
range of customers and businesses around
the world including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more you can use the code
TDPS 22
get a 20 british pound credit towards
cloud server options at signup tag adapt
calm /td PS with that you can try out
their services and save 20 british
pounds about 23 24 US dollars you use
the code TDPS 20 at sign up ta ga da be
calm /t dps check it out